[Music]
in cheating the system news my favorite
game submitted by John cone John Conan
Japanese youtuber broke the internet for
a day after selling shares of himself
online making almost five hundred
thousand dollars in one week Wow whoa
people own his body it's a lot of money
pretty what you could sell shares of
yourself that's crazy you Steve Jobs
capture sell shares of himself he's also
dead what when he was alive you know
what if I do buy shares of him I really
hope I don't get the [ __ ]
I like people the bus yeah cuz I that's
what I'm just assuming is like you know
some shares have different value than
the others yeah like maybe the nose yeah
[ __ ] might be the most valuable if
he's a virgin boy we're still talking
about Steve Jobs all the time oh we are
all the time on the Japanese guy yeah
but me see you one time
Japan has a new stock exchange platform
called value or in their language batter
you this platform here it allows users
to sell shares in themselves which means
but apparently it's a type of thing
where they can raise money to start a
business or like a professional like
personal three length oh cool and people
can like like buy a share in you that
makes sense
oh it's like a GoFundMe yeah a vest and
a person who start their own shoes
instead of investing the project you
invest in the person and when that
person makes money when they do their
taxes yet the money goes back into those
percentages I don't I'm not too fully
that the money goes back or not we
that's the part where I'm not too full
so it might be a GoFundMe where it's
just like give me money for my projects
the best bullshitter wins in that one
yeah you don't know nothing about them
they are saying that this thing it is in
beta so it's the iron
it's still pretty wrinkled yeah still
wrinkled those one Japanese youtuber
Naraku apparently exploited one of
values features to basically just cash
out on his popularity so he's a very
popular youtuber he has about 2.2
million subscribers was a lot yeah and
so when he announced that he was gonna
start this whole value thing he uses
popularity to the advantage where all of
his fans are a lot of his fans bought
shares in him invest in me
yeah and then so throughout this whole
thing he tweeted out that he wanted to
do something special and move his values
shares in one moment and so that at that
point that's when the price of his
shares skyrocketed and the following day
hiraku and his two other friends who
were also shipped to selling shares they
ended up cashing out fifty four million
six hundred and fifty thousand yen which
equals four hundred and ninety thousand
dollars in Bitcoin Wow
then fans found out that he did this he
pretty much it's so much bigger in yen I
was like who and this she converted oh
my god compared to the million I was
waiting for dollars that's why fifty
four million yeah yeah his fans were
pissed because they were like you know
you just manipulated this whole thing
and like I want my money back like I
believed in you and you just [ __ ] me
over
I was a hard p2 they were pissed pissed
oh yeah I'd be pissed
oh my god we're not investing that
[ __ ] what can he do
I don't trust anybody with [ __ ]
two-tone hair get me wrong
hey Carl Thank You Junior aku hey Carl
yeah you said her aku oh my bad I'm
Dyslexic but his real name is Ken
[Laughter]
damnit can ask the business value
profile and then why you do to space so
this is like an explanation just talking
about like getting started with a value
is simple make your own VA with just a
little investment in basic knowledge
like trading cards when you trade with
others you gain profit think of
incentives only you can offer value
either saying that for their users to
incentivize people to buy shares and
then that they can offer like you know a
special that only they can do like for
example like a day out with that
assumption I can make balloon animals
something yeah
but then this guy he didn't do any of
that he doesn't need to because he has a
lot of followers already that were
willing to invest in him about his
valley parlor to support him and this is
what happened I want the money back uh
what is the this oh this the fact that
he he pretty much manipulated the market
and he cashed out like they're looking
at the left picture it's like I I bought
this value to support him and then look
at the right picture and this is what
happened
what a [ __ ] you look so young why is he
showing it off cuz he's so young mmm so
young guy man it's a soul young and dumb
guy dad is young so split between three
friends $400,000 what a sack of [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude 2.2 mil he still has 2.2
mil after all that what what kind of
content does he make like Franco Braga
no gets hella views though yeah you done
like over a - than 1.5 million 2.7 do
that's sucks
let's bring him down here he does that I
wonder how like if his fans continue
watch him watching him and all that
stuff after this maybe you lost it off
maybe you have 10 million subscribers
now cuz people love that drama [ __ ] yeah
yeah but apparently they're saying that
since VA tokens are not considered a
financial product by Japan's Financial
Services Agency Hikaru and his friends
did not break any laws by manipulating
value so they don't face any legal
repercussions just yeah it's unethical I
don't think what they did was illegal
and I think it's just it's just really
shady because if you decide to make a go
fund me our fans just love us for who we
are and doesn't matter what project
we're gonna make they put in like a
million dollars but we decided to cash
out and go the product you know didn't
do so well or whatever I think they'll
be the same concept it's not illegal but
it's shady yeah or it's like we shoot
like a five dollar movie on an iPhone
when they gave us a million dollars like
technically if they gave us money we can
shoot whatever kind of movie would want
as long as we come up with the movie and
it's like a five dollar iPhone movie
then their to get pissed and then during
the illegal
but it's [ __ ] shady though yeah for
sure and he's so stupid to be taking
pictures or vlogging or whatever he did
with the money because if you use that
money to make your fans happy your value
just they're gonna love you even more
you're gonna make more people that are
short-sighted you know they're not gonna
last long all all the youtubers that I
know that we're very short-sighted they
didn't last as long as we did yeah
because they just find a way to [ __ ]
shady out their fans and [ __ ] and he
says that he only did it to get
attention and he recently announced that
he will be quitting YouTube so dope but
you didn't do to get attention he did it
get money be short-sighted sparking
together a ton of death threats so he
thinks 400,000 is a lot of money but
he's only 17 or 17 between 17 and 25
yeah but it you know that that money
doesn't last long if you spend lavishly
and you could have made more if you kept
your career going and kept your fans
happy I don't like this [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
like this
that [ __ ] ruins YouTube because it's
like because there's so many fake
pranksters so many [ __ ] swindlers
fraudsters all that [ __ ] on YouTube now
that like people get [ __ ] super
critical about all all of you to think
all youtubers are like that yeah cuz
like Steve Greene's pranks or were real
like simple pickups there we went with
them like they pick up girls for real
but they both get [ __ ] like because
there's so many fake pick up guys fake
prankster guys like they don't think
that it's real you know and I'm like
that really [ __ ] sucks because the
authenticity of YouTube just like you
know went to [ __ ] I mean even with us
people think that we script all this and
we all have a good memory
oh that's supposed to say after you guys
I wish this [ __ ] was scripted [ __ ] man
you know how much work like that would
be like to not think and just read I'll
be so easy they are saying that value
did
they already started making changes to
ensure that something like this never
happened again
their stock cells have now been limited
to a tenth of the total shares issued to
a single user per day and transactions
have been capped at 30 per day and the
daily price swings cannot fall more than
50 percent or rise more than 200 percent
so this for any user now yeah that's
[ __ ] up they [ __ ] it up for everyone
man there's so much [ __ ] like going
online now I feel like that's where
everything is going like all these apps
and like cryptocurrency and everything
and I'm just out of the loop and I'm
like I'm just trying to make people
laugh on YouTube I already feel like
this concept is is outdated okay so - so
what's the new [ __ ] man not people
writing jokes and hTML is [ __ ] cold in
parentheses you gotta learn how to
[ __ ] tell a joke through programming
yeah
my god hey Raul guys I hope you guys
enjoy the video please remember to give
us a big thumbs up and a like like like
and also when you guys sign on YouTube
make sure just kitty news is though
first thing you watch every single day
because we post videos every day okay
for more videos
[Music]